des mousquetaires des nobles des princes
et des princesses à versailles ce samedi
les enfants étaient à la fête pour la
deuxième édition d'un bal spécialement
créé pour eux c'est bien d'être je suis
très heureux d'être ici bas c'est drôle
parce que tu te prends relief et enfin
je veux tu joues tu fais ça avec tes
amis donc c'est encore mieux
la sensation découvrir de danser et des
rites et des migrants direction le xviie
siècle mais pas de musique baroque pour
ces enfants la musique actuelle est
interprétée par la chanteuse star dans
ce lieu prestigieux de l'orangerie un
hôte de marque à l'origine de ce ballet
kamel ouali chorégraphe de la star
academy ou de comédies musicales comme
les dix commandements
l'idée c'est de faire revivre aux gens
de notre époque
les grandes fêtes du château de
versailles à l'époque de louis xiv alors
avec une musique actuelle avec avec
voilà avec la nouvelle technologie avec
tout ça mais j'ai quand même cette
émotion que les gens à l'époque vous
pouvez vous pouvez vivre
les enfants se sont le temps d'une
après-midi transformer en prince et en
princesse le faste des bals du roi
soleil n'a rien perdu de sa superbe